it just makes sense too like
if if you're an alien from another
dimension or from another uni
another galaxy why would you just be
standing in the middle of a
a [ __ ] road okay so let's think about
this so if you
are an alien from some other realm
and you are you want to abduct someone
and if you show up as an alien standing
in the middle of the road they're going
to freak out
right so if you show up as something
familiar that wouldn't be that unusual
an owl then then okay oh there's an owl
on the side of the road
um you know so a deer on the side of the
road
it's a little murky when jesus shows up
but right so
but but so so they are so the
implication is they are using
an animal that wouldn't be unusual but
to see
and that um and that
that they are using some sort of screen
memory some sort of induced
hypnosis let's say to get into the mind
of the observer and
mess with it in a way that makes them
think they're seeing an owl when it when
in fact it's a gray alien standing in
front of them now
once like i get i cover that very early
on in my first book
the screen memory aspect and then i
i'm much more interested in the people
who are seeing real owls i think that's
much more fascinating to me
it's much more mysterious to me it's
i feel like it taints your research when
you go to a ufo conference and start
asking people about owls
because everyone's going to want to talk
about yeah that's connected to aliens or
whatever i feel like
if you go outside of people who are
interested in ufos just regular people
and ask them about owls have you ever
done that just like
sure casually asking asking people if
they've had any odd experience without
owls
all the time really yeah and owls are
such
weird weird animals like have you seen
i'm sure you've seen the videos of
people on youtube who have them
as pets and they just like they like
hang out with them they like pet them
and they
like they like chew on their finger a
little bit so they're very very
just like it's mind-bending the way they
move and this
their their aura that they have they're
there's a funny
there's a hilarious youtube comment on a
video somebody said owls
uh they're animals they have uh
bird hardware with cat software oh yeah
yeah so they can
yeah yeah so that so unlike other birds
most birds are sort of twitchy and
nervous looking they're
you know owls are not because so human
they're not scared they're
they're they're not twitchy and and kind
of like
jittery like normal birds are like even
a parakeet or a
parrot or something or or a seagull
they're they're just
they're what's crazy about owls is that
they're
they're like one of the top
predatory birds there are like like owls
kill hawks
yeah so
owls have specialized eyes to see in the
dark obviously they hunt in the dark
they fly in the dark they can fly
through the forest in almost complete
darkness
right they because of that they're all
their eyes are really big their eyes
collectively are bigger than their
brains
and then they also their eyes are not
shaped like a um
they're shaped more like a tube rather
than a circle
so we have circular eyeballs they're a
ball so we can look back and forth
owls can't do that their eyes are locked
straight ahead they cannot turn their
eyes side to side like any other bird
could
alright and because their aisles eyes
are locked forward
that's why they have that really weird
robotic head motion
because they use that so an owl and they
also very good they have wonderful night
vision they also have very
very good hearing so they can fly
at night in the forest through the trees
near complete darkness and they can
listen their feathers are specially
designed so they're very quiet
and they so they don't make any noise
when they fly so they can look down
and hear the sound of a mouse
on the ground while in flight and that's
how they hunt
right are there any other are there any
other birds or animals that have
eyes like that that are long and locked
in place
there i'm i would be i can't answer that
i don't think there are any other birds
i think it's only the owls that have the
the night vision hardware that's wild
so and um so
they uh yeah so i'll also
so they um they did some scientific
testing they put in
they had a totally dark they took a barn
they made it totally light tight
zero available light and then they could
control the amount of light
so they put light in that would be to
our eyes
undetectable like lower than we could
see
and then they put an owl up in the
rafter and then they have
they let mice go in the in the in the
bottom of the barn
and they said they had better results
when they put like forest stuff on the
ground so the
mice were like walking and making the
little crunchy noise like as if they
were walking across leaves and grass and
stuff
so they'd let a mouse go and the owl in
almost near darkness
would get the mouse 100 of the time
when they turned it to total darkness
the owl only using its ears
can't see anything would get the mouse
75 of the time that's roughly the data
wow so they are you don't stand much of
a chance if you're a little mouse in the
woods at night
do you think that the owls have the
ability to
see see into like another dimension
isn't that the question i have no idea i
would love that to i would that's a
great avenue of speculation and i had
fun speculating about that in the book
like it's i have no idea but isn't that
so that
if they can see into another dimension
that answers why they show up in haunted
house movies that answers why they show
up in ghost stories right ghosts come
from another dimension
well if any animal could see into
another dimension it would be an owl
right because they have the mo
the most advanced
visual sense and auditory sense
than probably any other animal right any
other vertebrae and their eyes are
so enormous and they can see and
virtually pitch black if any animal
could see into another realm it would be
an owl
yes so yes so that's my avenue of
thought like i would love
for that that would explain so much
right so can the owl like see through
time
does it know like like like that the ufo
is approaching
i know why does it all show up before
ufo then right if that given that logic
maybe there's like some like uh like the
the
the ufo gives off gamma rays and they
all can see it and the owls are curious
and they're just like wow what's that
thing over on the other side of the
forest i'm gonna fly over and look at it
right they're seeing something emanating
from the ufo the same way that
like like we can't hear a dog whistle
but the dog can and the dog can respond
to it maybe that maybe the flying saucer
is like a giant dog whistle to the
outside
but why did they show up before the the
ufo
yeah it's tough it's tough i mean i want
it it's a fun
it's a fun avenue of speculation
do you think they're do you think it
could be a possibility that their
the owls are trying to warn us about
something or do you think it's sort of
like the out the
the whatever the beings are are kind of
tapping into the owls
and trying to like make sure the coast
is clear
and make sure there's not going to be
any witnesses or something like that
if if that's the case then the owl is
absolutely the perfect animal to do that
right because they can see in the dark
and if you
if you're like you know if they if they
so that implies that they that the alien
somehow can read the mind of the owl
right so the owl flies into the location
they scope
it out they say okay you know there's
there's no
other witnesses here there's nobody else
on the street everyone else is in bed
i can hear that it's quiet if there was
someone in the house walking around the
owl would be able to hear it the owl
sitting on a
on a tree branch near the house it's not
going to cause any
you know it's not that interesting if
someone sees that or notices that at
night
if there's a gray alien standing in the
yard listening to the house
that might if a witness saw that if a
neighbor saw that it might be pretty
strange
so so yes so there's a there's a way to
think about that but
given that model the the ufo occupants
would have to tap into the mind of the
owl somehow
to like or did the can do they abduct
the owl and put a little sensor in it
just like
you know like like we would in a drone
you know like a little video camera in
the
in the owl it doesn't seem too
far-fetched that they could they could
tap into
to the vision of an owl or tap in to the
mind of an owl just to
use it as kind of like a surveillance
surveillance
cameras little be the perfect
surveillance camera yeah i speculate
about that in the book and i
and i'm cautious because i i get
dead-ended any time i go down that road
because like why would they do that why
is it happening so often what's going
what's really going on